[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on pourrait facilement penser que la
pièce la plus importante de tout mon
équipement
c'est mon âme le sabre l'épée le fleuret
rapidement une maj nous viennent en tête
avec la france d'armes aux ja il m'a
fallu plusieurs années pour comprendre
que la pièce la plus puissant de tout
mon équipement
c'est pas mon sambre eh bien non c'est
plutôt mon masque il est parfois mon
führer dab adversaires mais
majoritairement du temps c'est mon plus
grand allié dans toutes les sphères de
ma vie et à toutes les étapes
aujourd'hui je me présente devant vous
le visage n y à nu mais pas tout à fait
je me rappelle très bien ma première
interaction avec mon masque
j'avais à peine six ans le scream c'est
une affaire de famille puisque mon père
ma mère mon frère l'entraînent et
l'empreinte ce qui un beau matin après
avoir regardé les entraînements mon
grand frère plus de deux ans finalement
c'était à mon tour 15 gym immense pour
la première fois j'ai ressenti comme une
décharge électrique dans tout le corps
comme si c'était ça va être toujours
fait partie de moi
une extension qui me donnait accès à mon
homme à mon coeur à mon corps des
parties j'avais jamais d'idées est mal
c'était incroyable comme comme sentiment
et ça marche le fameux suivi pendant
longtemps a déjà à l'âge de 13 ans le
monde s'ouvrait pas moins mais
département partout dans le pays et
ailleurs dans le monde
ils sont multipliées cet âge là que j'ai
eu mes premiers championnats gt fébrile
à l'idée d'avoir l'opportunité de
verbaliser candidats partout dans le
monde mais surtout la petite fille de
chicago qui tend - était extrêmement
fier de représenter son pays pour la
toute première fois
aussitôt mmm à se placer sur matin
j'avais une énergie une envie de jouer
mais abu aita sans trop me poser de
questions pourtant pour la toute
première fois j'ai perdu la majorité de
mes combats
et pour la toute première fois j'ai
détesté mon sport j soudainement eu
envie d'enlever mon masque fille de
lancer le plus loin possible et c'est là
que mon père mon entraîneur m en
récession il m'a regardé et m'a dit
sales draps
si tu travailles fort site ou basso si
tous les outils nécessaires
un jour tu iras où je l'aï dit je vous
jure il parle vraiment comme ça cette
phrase ne me rentrer vraiment à ça m'a
marqué c'est dans la compétition
intéressante je me suis dit si des
objectifs de performances passées levé
un peu trop élevé à erpent ci puisque
même après mes entraînements j'avais pas
tout à fait mon masque j'étais en tout
temps en mode combat est mon principal
adversaire
c'était moi en pleine crise
d'adolescence mettait vraiment rude
épreuve la confiance que j'avais en ma
capacité et à ce moment là j'étais seul
avec ce masque leur qu'il semblait de
plus en plus lourd j'étais obsédé par la
performance et ça m'a amené dans des
endroits de mon âme de mon coeur à ses
hôtes que il m'a fallu plusieurs années
pour vraiment familiariser avec ce monde
intérieur pour finalement comprendre que
je devais lâché prise que je devais
vraiment plus me centrer sur le moment
présent et d'arrêter de me projeter vers
la performance
cette conscientisation l'homme me permit
de prendre une
chemin avec mon masque un chemin ou bien
faire les choses qui sont à ma portée de
prendre soin de moi de mes entraînements
de mes proches ma permis ça ça m'a
vraiment permis de jouir pleinement du
moment présent sans trop penser au
résultat
ça m'a pris plus de 20 années pour
finalement obtenir mon premier billet
pour les premiers jeux olympiques soit
ceux de 2008 à beijing
mais plus mais surtout ça m'a pris plus
de 20 années pour apprivoiser ce fameux
masque
je vais tenter avec la prochaine
histoire de vous faire vivre puisque le
rôle que je jouais mon masque dans ma
quête de gloire olympique pour ma
deuxième qualifications soit quatre ans
plus tard pour l'ombre 2008
alors je vous situe on it à moscou en
l'enjeu est énorme parce que c'est la
dernière compétition qualification
olympique
je suis la seule sabreuse canadienne est
à cette compétition
dans cette quête olympique mais
heureusement je peux compter sur
l'amitié et la complicité que j'ai bâtie
avec koubbi au but une escrimeuse
allemande qui tout comme moi rêve de
représenter son pays dans la compétition
la plus prestigieuse qui soit on pense
une bonne soirée la veille de la
compétion à discuter à échanger mais
entre autres de dire que ce serait un
rêve de vivre les jeux ensemble à
londres
comme la tradition le tableau d'une
nation direct est affichée dans le mille
l'hôtel la veille la compétition
aussitôt que le tableau a été affichée
koubi monde a sa chambre parce qu'elle a
l'habitude d'éviter d'un rock de conakry
danse et areeba la veille de la
compétition tandis que moi jacques
ouvert les tableaux pour finalement
reconnaître qu'avec mon adversaire
ma première adversaire
matin le pire scénario serait à mes yeux
mon adversaire c'est koubbi j'ai
aussitôt le cou le souffle coupé mon
visage qui se crispe je monte à ma
chambre sachant dorénavant que ça sera
entre elles - à la différence que pour
moi ce combo leur représente une
occasion de concrétiser ma qualification
qui était déjà bien en avant c'est parce
que pour elle ça passe ou ça casse
le lendemain matin je me réveille d'une
nuit éprouvante où je tout les scénarios
de me sont venues en tête le sens même
du ta qualification est presque fait
peut pas lui faire ça dans une
malheureuse ma raison me dit tu dois
gagner ton combat confirmer la
qualification
une seule conclusion est logique je dois
gagner je vois ici de tout faire pour
gagner mon combat contre mon amie ma
complice masters dames koubbi ça y est
l'arbre était prêt mon ami aussi et aux
mamans poignée monsabré mon masque qui
me surprend le dire ici je la laissais
le maman pas mon masque et lemaitre sur
matin il me semble interminable mais
mizidy s'envole dans toutes les
directions
mais heureusement aussitôt que j'y lis
mon masque sur la tête
en une fraction de seconde j'ai une
énergie qui me remplit qui était animée
par tous les enfants que j'avais
déployés pour arriver à ce moment le
bien précis le comble qu'on bossait sur
demande si vite et ça s'est joué à la
dernière touche 14 14
les deux ont fait une action qui touche
la ceiba lab la bible doit trancher
ils disent prenant la taxe touche point
combat combo sassine je viens de
remporter mon match et de concrétiser ma
qualification pour me2 cm jeux
olympiques
mais au moment d'enlever mon masque
j'aperçois ma meilleure amie
s'effondrer au sol sans hésitation j'ai
lâché mon masque qui a couvert ses côtés
de front a pleuré pendant un bon moment
je vous rassure moi puis koubbi on est
encore de très bons amis puis on va
l'être encore pour longtemps
mais une chose est certaine c'est que je
suis extrêmement fier d'avoir pu faire
la part des choses cette journée là ça
me pris 28 ans en tant qu'athlète 28 ans
avec ce masque à 28 en escrime
je peux vous dire que ma transition dans
la vie professionnelle fut un réel choc
même si je me suis trouvé un travail
très stimulant dans mon champ d'étude
aux films comme terre et pékin
j'allais juste qu'à me cacher dans la
salle de bain pour aller faire des
pochettes des heureusement si le passage
de visage masqué au visage à nu me fait
perdre mes repères pour un bref instant
pour un bref un oui parce que rapidement
je me suis rendu compte que
instinctivement d'une certaine façon mon
masque était pas très loin et qui sera
leur pendant dans les moments les plus
importants pour moi je me rappelle à
peine quelques semaines après mes débuts
au comité olympique où on me demandait
de co animer une soirée avec un midi
olympique et se sent très peu de temps
de préparation lors que précéder m'a
monté sur scène vomit dans un i-pod
angoisse que j'avais peur ressentie
depuis ma retraite d'athlète mais quand
j'ai réalisé que je vais aborder cette
situation le dit précise comme un combat
escrime
ça m'a permis d'aller chercher cette
concentration il y avait besoin pour
livrer la commande
je suis mon pic sur scène je me suis
surprise à reconnaître cet état de l'ue
ce t2 focus qui me permettait justement
d'avoir les idées claires de vraiment
jouir du moment sans trop y penser au
résultat
à travers mon parcours autant a pas
quatre parades dans ma vie
professionnelle j su puiser dans ce que
toujours été pour moi un catalyseur
d'inspiration de créativité et de
persévérance
on a probablement tous ressenti site de
grâce qui nous permettait de repousser
les limites qu'on pensait
infranchissable
le défi réside dans le fait de
reconnaître le moment que c'était de
l'eau a été ressentie le défi c'est
d'être capable de le reproduire de
manière contrôlée de manière contrôlée
est consciente
alors je vous laisse avec l'arrêt de la
question suivante quel est votre masque
[Applaudissements]